it was very much indeed for talking to
us here today now you're working on the
release of a film called unstoppable and
extension of the like a girl campaign so
tell us a little bit about what that
films about and why you've chosen to get
involved so I'm here as you said for the
launch of the new like a girl
unstoppable like a girl video and I'm
here in New York speaking to a lot of
people who are all helping to inspire
young women to not lose their confidence
through puberty it's something that
we've seen so often that young girls
feel limited by society there's been so
many social experience experiments done
that actually back this knowledge and
they feel like they're putting boxes by
society and they're constantly told what
they should or shouldn't do and that's
why I'm here is to break down those
boundaries and make sure every girl
feels like they are unstoppable well
that's right and a lot of it is about is
it not reclaiming that phrase like a
girl and making it a positive thing
rather than a negative thing because at
the moment you might say running like a
girl or crying like a girl as a kind of
derogatory comment how do you turn that
into a positive thing I feel like we
need to strip back what we know about
this phrase like a girl and look at you
know the hard evidence behind it what
does that actually mean you throw like a
girl I know plenty of girls that you
know in the Olympics in sports that can
do things you know do things like
fantastically and it has nothing to do
with the fact that there are a girl or
men that can do things fantastically and
it has nothing to do with the fact that
they're a man people are good at
different things and they have qualities
in life but you know to pass others and
that's the way it goes and I feel like
it's something that we now need to to
diminish and and teach the next
generation of young girls that actually
it's okay to throw like a girl cuz it
means you're a damn good thrower and
you're just 18 but you started filming
with the game of thrones cast at just
the age of 12 so you must have had to
grow up incredibly fast how difficult is
it to go through that stage of life in
such a public way yeah I started Game of
Thrones when I was 12 so it was
the time where I was I hadn't hit
puberty and I was still a young girl who
hadn't experienced any any limitations
from the society it's not until I got
older that I realized playing a
character that smashes gender
stereotypes is actually a really big
deal and it's not something that we've
seen too often and i always saw that as
just a normal girl and you know who I
was I didn't realize that it was
different for a girl to to act that way
so you know working on the show from a
young age I have found my confidence and
found who i am a lot earlier than a lot
of other people I've been lucky enough
to have a great support group of a like
family around me to to support me in the
decisions that I make but I know that
it's not the case for everyone and not
just because they don't have the support
network but because there's just not the
knowledge and not the teaching of
confidence in young girls and that's
what Ted and always have partnered
together to create a confidence
curriculum to be taught in schools
globally and yeah it's something that I
wish that I had when I was a lot younger
and I know a lot of girls would really
really benefit from so I've been lucky
enough to find Who I am on my own but I
know that a lot of girls can't do that
and haven't done that but they deserve
to on the subject of Game of Thrones and
on the subject of women as well there
was a big reaction to the rape scene
that occurred in the last series of your
characters sister it even got American
senators tweeting about it what's your
feeling about that route I feel like in
Game of Thrones there was a lot of very
strong characters that are depicted in
the time that game of thrones is set
women were treated awfully and we have
to show both sides to really appreciate
where how far we've come in society I'm
lucky enough and sophie is lucky enough
to play a really really strong female
character and we can't decide what
happens to our characters and with a lot
of other fantasy shows that is
controversial topics but I am devoted to
making sure that girls around the world
fill in pilot feel empowered and I'm
strong